tonight I'm Brian Ross investigates how
America tortures depicted in the new
Amazon film the report they waterboarded
him 183 times waterboarding speeding is
cruel everything they got from him was
either a lie or something they already
had and now these chilling sketches
drawn by the first terror suspects
himself who went through the torture
program his lawyer just back from
Guantanamo will join us with the latest
plus the plight of former FBI agent Bob
Levinson missing in Iran for almost 13
years his family has gone to court to
demand that Iran own up and pay up their
lawyer claims new evidence that Bob
Levinson is still alive we have reason
to believe that he is alive and our
shouta for the investigative reporter
who tracked how a powerful member of
Congress lived a life of luxury
using his campaign funds as a personal
piggy bank stories that federal
prosecutors say helped lead to the
congressman's indictment the fact is
that the case began when Morgan cook
published an article in the UT there was
a very much caught off-guard because
usually and when people call us out it's
not to tell us a great job we did and
how much we hoped and how important we
are from the law and crime Network
studios in New York City's Herald Square
this is Brian Ross investigates
good evening and welcome tonight we
begin with the story of the first
suspected terrorists captured by the CIA
after the September 11th attacks and
then tortured and held in limbo to this
day he has not been charged with any
crime and may never be the u.s. may want
to forget about Abu Zubaydah but a new
film and new reports about the secretive
US torture program make it impossible to
ignore what happened to him his lawyer
mark 10-ball is standing by to talk less
and the latest coming as commandos
forced their way into the room with one
man flees for the roof trying to escape
to the next building the capture of Abu
Zubaydah by the CIA in Pakistan was at
first portrayed as America's striking
back at the terrorists who carried out
the 9/11 attacks
Abu Zubaydah we knew was going to be a
wealth of information but since then the
reality has been more troubling as Abu
Zubaydah became the first suspected
terrorist to undergo what the CIA called
enhanced interrogation but later even
the president called torture the new
Amazon film the report reveals the
efforts by Senator Dianne Feinstein and
her staff investigator Daniel Jones to
expose what was going on they
waterboarded him 183 times everything
they got from him was either a lie or
something they already had
Abu Zubaydah has been held at the u.s.
prison in Guantanamo Cuba since 2006 in
what is known as camp number seven he
now wears a patch over one eye due to an
unspecified injury he suffered while in
US captivity he is not free to speak
publicly but through his lawyer has made
public drawings he's sketched of the
treatment he says he received at one of
the u.s. black sites where the tortured
program was carried out hung by his arms
naked confined to a small box beaten on
the face water border
graphic evidence of what he says he went
through the CIA had video tapes of their
interrogations but they were destroyed
so the world could never see what went
on in the name of US justice the CIA
officer who oversaw the program Jose
Rodriguez
defended the destruction of the tapes in
this interview with the BBC there was
later seen around the world but did you
say yes I think the tapes were viewed
outside of the CIA became public they
would make us look terrible and it would
be devastating yes did you say that of
course I said that yes so all that is
left now are the drawings of Abu
Zubaydah we're joined now by mark
Denville the lawyer for Abu Zubaydah and
a professor at the Seton Hall University
School of Law in New Jersey and director
of its Center for Policy and research
mr. Denbo thank you for being here I
know you're just back from visiting your
client at Guantanamo what is the latest
well I've this is the first time I've
seen him since the his pictures were
made public and the American people were
shocked and horrified in ways that I
never expected and I had thought
everybody was inured to the horror of
all of this and he was relieved to find
out that there were people who thought
what was done to him was horrible and
that he at least felt like he's buried
in a sense in the southeast corner of
Cuba sticking out the Atlantic and
nobody knows anything about him but at
least I think it's fair to say people
are more aware of him and realized what
terrible things let me ask you about
some of those sketches that he drew and
that you've made public one of them
shows him apparently manacled and then
hanging from bars what are we seeing
there with that particular sketch well
there were a series of techniques they
called generally there would either be
stress positions so one of them would be
to have him standing very high up with
his arms apart generally said sometimes
so he's held to have to be on his
tiptoes the whole time other times it's
spread apart one of those there shows
him having to urinate because of course
he never had access to any toilet
facilities or any hygiene and I might
add I think one of the things that is
incredibly humiliating and painful for
him is the idea he was kept naked
constantly day after day week after week
and month after month
in front of women there's another sketch
which appears to see him being slapped
by a guard or a CIA officer well that's
actually called walling with America has
special categories of slapping walling
is one where you have somebody standing
away from near a wall but not next to it
and while you're interrogating them with
the towel wrapped around their neck you
end up that they will intermittently
when asking questions suddenly slam them
backwards into a wall hitting their head
and that is an example of an
interrogator shoving him into the wall
and the wall weight head would then hit
the wall and as others have described
there's an echoing resonance in their
brain that is shocking and they're never
quite sure when it will happen or how
hard it will be and there are our
psychiatrists down booth told me that
that is causing brain damage not unlike
CTE s with the National Football League
in all of this did they get any useful
information from Abu Zubaydah no I you
know this is the part of it that in some
ways the worst torture is to have the
world not know that you were never a
member of al-qaeda because the CIA
admits he wasn't al-qaeda everything
they said that he had ever done such as
terrorist acts he had never done any he
had never been involved in any attacks
or groups attacking the United States in
fact Osama bin Laden asked him to join
al-qaeda and he refused for a variety of
reasons and one was America wasn't his
enemy and so let me ask you and Mark let
me ask you this we just have a minute
left here he has not been charged with a
crime is he going to be he's never been
charged with a crime he sits there
waiting for somebody to charge him with
a crime and as we know the CIA would
just before they tortured him said he
would have to be held incommunicado for
the rest of his life once they tortured
him that was assuming he didn't die and
what's happened is he's been held so the
only people he's spoken to have been
we'll think of this the tortures
jailers and his lawyers which is
essentially me that's all
since 2002 and it looks like it'll be
all forever because they won't give him
a trial because they don't want him to
talk amazing story professor dan bow
thank you so much for joining us keep us
posted on the next developments there it
certainly will Brian okay up next the
sad story of another man whose family
won't let him be forgotten former FBI
agent Bob Levinson last seen alive in
Iran if he is alive former FBI agent
Robert Levinson would be America's
longest held hostage last seen alive in
Iran in March of 2007 and now his
distraught family once the government
Iran to own up to taking him and to pay
up to us known proof that Bob Levinson
was alive
a disturbing hostage video sent to his
family and the US government eight years
ago
Levinson disappeared almost 13 years ago
in Iran on the island of Kish where he
had gone on an unauthorized CIA mission
he met there with this man
Dawood salahuddin an American wanted for
murder in the u.s. for the killing of an
Iranian diplomat in Washington diode
said Iranian security forces took
Levinson away but since then Iranian
officials have repeatedly denied any
knowledge of his whereabouts
earlier this month Levinson's family his
seven adult children and his wife
Christine went to a US Court in
Washington in a lawsuit against the
government of Iran asking the judge to
award them 1.5 billion dollars no one
from Iran appeared in court two
answer the charges we're joined now by
Dave McGee a lawyer in Pensacola Florida
who represents the Levinson family
mr. McGee thanks for being here you had
two days of testimony in a courtroom in
Washington with members of Bob's family
testifying for all accounts it was very
emotional testimony it was it was
remarkable I have done this for 44 years
tried cases and I've never seen one that
was more emotional than this this family
has been it was it was obviously this
family had been through trauma for the
last 13 years and very difficult to sit
there with dry eyes I don't think there
was a dry eye in that courtroom very
moving testimony mr. McGee does the
family believe that Bob Levinson is
still alive it's been almost 13 years
now they do they do there are reasons
that I can't discuss for them believing
that but but they and I believe that he
is still alive not going into those
reasons is there some kind of evidence
you have yes there is evidence evidence
which I cannot discuss but there is
evidence we have we have reason it's not
just it's not just fancy we have reason
to believe that he is alive and in the
custody of the Iranian government there
recently was a prisoner swap between the
United States and Iran but Bob Levinson
wasn't part of it that when and that was
what while we applaud mr. Wang's release
and then wish him well that was very
painful for the Levinson family and the
friends and Bob looked to see once again
all those released while he states
listen McGee a question for you from our
control room from the executive producer
Rhonda Schwartz Rhonda what's your
question
Ayatollah is this really practical do
you expect something to come out of this
can there be a real result from this
yeah there can't be a real result and
there's a couple of answers to that
first of all the family will recover
some from a congressional fund that's
set up for people who have been the
victims of terrorist countries like this
and they will they will recover some
amount of money from
secondly we are free to search the world
for Iranian assets and see if we can
grab and seize Iranian assets which we
will do we have already assembled the
team and will be looking for Iranian
assets and finally Wow
Iran is at odds with much of the world
at this time and their assets are not
not easily gotten it at some point
Iran is gonna have to come back into the
world of Commerce they're gonna want to
do business they're gonna want to go
through American banks because you can't
do a lot of commerce without going
through American banks and at that point
they will be vulnerable to judgments
such as ours and we anticipate that
we're we're looking both in short term
and long term let me ask you this the
role of the US government of all of this
the families been highly critical of
many aspects of what the US has done or
failed to do they they have been we have
been very disappointed with the FBI's
performance in this case now having said
that there are elements of the US
government that has tried very hard to
assist the Levinson family but those who
were primarily responsible for the
investigation and recovery of Bob I mean
look he's been there 13 years and they
haven't recovered and that says a lot
right there but this family like other
hostage families has been disappointed
with the performance of the FBI and how
about the Trump administration have you
seen the difference with this
administration based on a previous
administration's performance it is yeah
and let me say this with the appointment
of Robert O'Brien as national security
adviser who was involved when he was the
White House hostage in charge of white
for the white house for hostage
negotiations his involvement plus the
involvement of some people at the State
Department right now is leaves us makes
us very hopeful there are some good
people working very hard right now we
believe to get mr. Levinson out and for
that we are thankful and do people in
the US government share your optimism
that he might get out that he in fact
maybe still be alive
there are people in the US government
that Dushi
my optimism there and some that don't
it's a very complex issue and I thought
and and one that has has been a thorn in
the side of various government agencies
for a long time I think there's some
kind of at times you wonder if they just
wish this thing when wouldn't just go
away but it's not going to go away he's
got seven children our wife who are
dogged in their pursuit of his freedom
and I'm sure we'll stay on it if it
takes another 20 years they will they
will be in the search for Bob Levinson
and no doubt this is another painful
holiday season for them without their
father grandfather their husband the
other part of it that makes this case
different than any other is he's still
there as I said here talking to you Bob
Levinson sits in some Iranian dungeon
okay in the possession of a hostile
power that we all know tortures American
prisoners who have done this before who
have done it repeatedly and that their
their mission is not over their wound
cannot heal if mr. Levinson had passed
away 13 years ago it would be a painful
memory but that wound would be healed by
now
this wound does not heal because every
day they have to get up and do something
to get their father their husband back
to be arranged and to repeat you are
confident the family remains confident
that Bob Levinson is in fact alive still
being held in Iran yes he's still there
and their Iranian is having David McGee
thank you so much for joining us keep us
posted on new developments thank you
Brian
up next our shoutout for a reporter
whose investigation exposed at
congressman living a life of luxury
using his campaign money as his personal
piggy bank
and our shutout tonight for an
investigative reporter at the San Diego
union-tribune
whose work is now being credited by
federal prosecutors as being the spark
that led to the indictment and
conviction of a five turn Republican
congressman who faces prison and later
this month plans to resign his position
it was a thousand dollars spent on video
games that led to the downfall of a
popular California Republican
congressman congressman Duncan Hunter
blamed his teenage son saying he
mistakenly build some thirteen hundred
dollars to his campaign instead of using
the family's personal credit card but at
the San Diego Union Tribune reporter
Morgan Cooke wasn't buying that excuse
as she discovered other questionable
expenditures in the records the
congressman had filed we searched for
oral and facial surgery we saw a new
garage door
there were strange patterns of charges
lots of gas stations lots of grocery
stores just a fast-food a $229 charge at
the star trader store at Disneyland that
the congressman claimed was for food and
beverages for the campaign so I call and
I'm like what kind of food do you guys
have and I said well we have Pez and a
Star War themed rice krispies treat I
was like wow somebody's gonna have a
tummy ache prosecutors would later
document of $9,200 trip to Italy for
Hunter and his wife Margaret who also
pleaded guilty to a criminal count along
with traveled to Hawaii resorts in
Arizona money spent in Washington
allegedly to pay for a series of
extramarital affairs even $600 in
airfare for the family pet rabbit named
Egbert Cook says she knew almost
immediately she was on to something big
you know we couldn't really let it go
it's like every question we answered
there was another question
other question and everywhere he looked
there was another question so he
couldn't really let up hunter first
elected in 2008 and succeeding his
father of the same name was a well-known
and popular figure in the halls of
Congress and as prosecutors closed in he
said he was being investigated for what
were only accounting mistakes calling it
a witch-hunt aimed at him because he was
an outspoken defender of President Trump
they could try to have a political
agenda as our law enforcement as a US
government I think we've seen with
strong and and what the FBI and the DOJ
have been doing let's let them expose
themselves for what they are and then
that's a politically motivated group of
folks but earlier this month the
congressman changed his to pleading
guilty to one count of conspiracy to
convert campaign funds to personal use
likely now facing time in prison when he
is sentenced next year I failed to
monitor and account for my campaign
spending I made mistakes and that's what
today was all about the federal
prosecutor on the case Phil Halpern said
there was nothing political about it
that the investigation began only after
he read the reporting by Morgan Cooke in
the San Diego union-tribune
the fact is that the case began when
Morgan Cooke published an article in the
UT I read that article I discussed it
with Emily Allen and then mark Conover I
went to the FBI and we said look at this
is there a case and after that we went
we consulted with people in DOJ who in
this administration made the decision
you know to indict representative hunk
hunter nothing could have been more
apolitical than the process that was
involved here in fact today in many ways
is a triumph for the press and shows the
importance of having a free press that
not only can the people rely on but that
the Department of Justice can turn to
for guidance
Cooke was one of the reporters outside
the courthouse and was stunned to hear
what the prosecutor had to say about her
I think that's what I heard but that
doesn't sound like something that I
would hearing there was a very much
caught off guard because usually when
people call us out it's not to tell us a
great job we did and how much we helped
and how important we are it Cook became
an overnight journalism sensation her
reporting cited by the networks and
national newspapers a major career break
I think it would take a lot for me to
leave San Diego I think I just still
learn a lot here I can still grow here I
can still do the work that I'm capable
of here and it's a really special
newsroom because everyone is on everyone
else's team and they helped carry me if
I could do it better with help they
contributed their skill and I've just
been really lucky to be in a newsroom
where I have colleagues who support me
and support this work and are willing to
give what they can to see that Morgan
Cooke told me she survived one newspaper
she worked for closing down another one
let her go but she hung in there and
clearly has made quite a name for
herself doing the kind of hard-hitting
work we just don't see enough of anymore
that's our program for tonight thanks
for joining us and best wishes this
holiday season from all of us Rhonda
Ariel Jennifer Alex and our incredibly
talented technical crew we'll see you
back here next week good night
you